yoku boo is only two years old his short
life has already experienced
unimaginable horrors his family's
village was overrun by Boko Haram
militants his mother only managed to
escape with him at the last second Kaku
Buu is severely malnourished there
wasn't much to eat while his family was
on the run and now safe and Maiduguri
they have no money for the last month I
could see he wasn't doing well I gave
him traditional medicine but it wasn't
helping he kept getting weaker and
weaker at first he would eat the paste I
made for him from peanuts but then he
didn't want it anymore
it was almost too late by the time his
mother heard about Doctors Without
Borders she couldn't afford a regular
Hospital here the treatment is free and
it's super crazy we are seeing about 100
250 pregnant women a day is a huge
challenge but we try to keep our teams
well motivated and you can imagine
you're seeing hundred two hundred and
fifty malnourished babies it's bound to
like heavy weigh on you in fact the
number of patients keeps rising
Nigeria's poverty-stricken north suffers
from chronic food shortages the threat
posed by Boko Haram makes it impossible
for many farmers to grow their crops
more than 250 mothers and children are
coming to this treatment facility every
day for many of them it is not an easy
decision because this part of Maiduguri
was under control of Boko Haram for a
long time even the clinic building
itself used to be a building of the
terrorists
in total Doctors Without Borders treats
more than 1,500 patients every day in
their three clinics in Maiduguri an
estimated one and a half million
refugees has more than doubled the
city's population the local government
is overwhelmed it focuses its efforts on
the official camps for internally
displaced persons well wouldn't somebody
there are also refugees who aren't being
counted because they're living with
relatives so they're not identified as
refugees they're surviving from the help
of locals and their relatives as long as
they aren't registered they don't get
free access to state services like free
hospital care georgina methylation
that's why your kuboos family haven't
received any support from the state
Yakubu is now being treated at a special
clinic his mother hopes he'll regain
health and that shall finally get
government support at least providing
enough food to eat